next peak
will be richard from asml and
he'll be talking about missing data
which is i think a very common
problem so if i'm not mistaken do you uh
you have a background in speech
recognition right yes yes
so is this similar to the work you're
currently doing at the html
yeah the speech recognition because the
missing data problem is not actually a
problem
in a speech we usually have a huge
amount of speech available
and um that was not a challenge when i
was a phd student and that was a
challenge actually i
encountered when i came to industry yeah
okay
interesting well the floor is all yours
thank you yeah of course
um all right um
so um well thank you for the
introduction
um uh today in this presentation i'm
going to
talk about um one of the maybe most
common issues or challenges that you may
face
so long as you work with real data or
industrial data
and that's missingness and uh the the
reason that i've uh
chosen to uh give this presentation
today is that first of all as someone
who works with uh asml
um well we work with a lot of uh missing
data you know the
majority of the big part of the data
that we work with is coming from asmr
machines and
uh well um for a number of reasons we do
not always have all the measurements
available
for example some measurements are very
expensive and we don't want to do that
for
all the way fares or samples but
more importantly and maybe more
generally as a data scientist or
engineer or
deal with missing data and i believe
it's not some optional skills you may
want to have or not
it's a necessity and as an implementer
or
well particularly python user you also
need to know what's happening
uh in the packages you use or what's
happening behind the scene in the code
and here are two examples that i hope
uh make is going to make you motivated
to listen to me for the
rest of this presentation so one of them
is about
three of the common packages in python
random forest from scikit-learn light
gradient boosting method and extreme
gradient boosting method
and um these packages actually work
totally differently towards missing data
one of them
the cycler1 returns error it doesn't
work with missing data
and the other two uh like light gradient
boosting uh by default replaces zero by
missing values which i said
which i would say it's not really a
smart and the last one extremely ideal
boosting does something fairly smart but
ad hoc to its uh
own structure or uh to other operations
uh popular operations especially in
image processing like max pooling and
average pulling from
a subclass of layers in keras uh one of
them simply ignores missing values and
the other one
uh considers that so um
the the key point here is that uh we
need to be vigilant about
even the code that we make uh regarding
the way it works with missing data
so in this presentation and the way that
i'm going to forward today is to first
take one step back and talk about
missing data maybe more fundamentally
the reason that it happens and why it's
important to to
uh be careful about it and
but maybe the most important part is the
type and the origin of missingness
because the approach that you're going
to take to deal with missing data early
depends
on the information you can collect by
knowing these
things about your data and i'm going to
also talk about
methodologies that you can use to work
around missing data problem
but i'm not planning to go technically
into one or two methods because simply
there is no one-size-fits-all solution
for for missing data and usually uh to
to be able to
choose the right method you need to uh
actually have enough
have a good understanding about your
data to actually find the one which
suits you the best
i'm going to also show you some examples
i have some uh
notebooks jupiter notebooks that i'll
make sure you will have access to
uh it's on uh google collab so you can
simply rerun it
and uh especially if you have not done
much in
the missing data invitation before it's
going to be greater start for you to get
acquainted to
uh some open toolboxes like psychic
learn or fancy impute to do the
imputation
all right uh why a missingness and why
where it comes from um well there are a
number of reasons for that
as i said um at asml for example cost or
expenses uh
one one uh important reason that we have
missing data but there are other reasons
to like
um i don't know the privacy or even the
fault or mistake from the machine or
uh the human who collects the data but
the more important question we should
ask
is that why we should care about missing
data and i would like to view it in two
ways that
one side of the story is that um
majority or almost
all of the machine learning or ai data
science related methods
are developed relying on assumption that
the data is complete and if you have
incomplete data you need to find a way
to map incomplete data to a complete one
and another side story which is uh well
equally
important is to be able to do the
imputation or to fill in the missing
values
uh with the right and accurately enough
candidates because we don't want to mess
up with your data by adding noise or
bias to to the data set
and to be able to find the right way we
need to uh
the first step is to understand the
types of the missingness and
it's well according to many of the uh
literature
a big part of the literature it can be
categorized into three groups
the first one is called missing
completely at random and
in this case um there is no particular
reason that data is missing
but also there is no relationship or
dependency between the observed
variables and the missing
well the missing the valuable variables
with missing values
so in this case i've uh made a handmade
example
uh assumed that assuming that we had a
question or ask in some part it's been
feeling some information about their
salary and their gender
and um in this case two people didn't
mention anything about salary
so uh there is no i mean the data
doesn't suggest that and also we don't
have any prior knowledge that men or
women
are more inclined to talk about salary
and also let's
hope that we are living in a world with
no gender discrimination so we cannot
make any guess or estimate of the salary
according to the gender then this is
called missing
completely at random and for the missing
at random one
uh well as confusing as it sounds with
the first one there is a huge difference
and
in this case there is a correlation or
dependency between the missing values
and observed ones
so in our example if you ask the
participant to
tell us how experienced they are then
both the data and our
common sense tells us that there is a
relationship or correlation between the
amount of
the salary and how experienced someone
is
so this is called missing as random and
the last one is called missing not at
random and this is the most difficult
one because
in many cases we can't do or let's say
we cannot make a good estimate for the
missing values because we don't have
enough information about that
and um in our example let's assume that
we ask the participant for their
positions in the company
and we realized that whenever the uh the
person is a ceo we don't have any
information about the salary
so um there could be a reason for that
but we are not aware of it it's this
could be for example ceos don't have a
fixed salary or they don't want others
or us feel bad about our own salary
either way we don't have enough
information to make a good estimate of
that
and before going further i would also
like to make some points
uh first of all distinguishing the type
of the missingness is not easy and
sometimes it's even impossible
and sometimes our data has a number of
kind of
uh let's say missing uh data
and these are all sources of confusion
and complication and that's why
that's one reason that missing data can
be very challenging
for your task and um also
before trying to distinguish the type of
the missingness you need to be sure that
you know enough about your data
the data is complete enough or is
balanced enough
and uh just maybe as a rule of thumb uh
you will find that in many cases people
already assume that the data is missing
at
random just to make life easier for
themselves but
obviously this is not an accurate
assumption
so how to deal with missingness um
well if we should uh and that means that
if you have enough information to do the
imputation or to take any action
obviously
one uh scenario is to drop or ignore
missing values and i particularly
mentioned the art of dropping because as
maybe it sounds trivial
but it actually is not and it can really
uh be very tricky and dangerous and
to be able to uh make this important
decision
whether to drop or ignore the missing
values or not you need to have a good
understanding on
many factors around your data like how
much information you would lose by
removing
or dropping those samples and
if there is another or better approach
to take
the other kind of action that you may
take is to impute
and that means to fill in the missing
values with some um
let's say guess or estimation and this
can be done uh generally in two ways
which is which are called single
amputation and multiple imputation the
single computation as a name suggests
uh simply uh provides us with one
version or one uh
imputed version of the incomplete data
so in this case the red
square shows the missing entries and
it's imputed by the single imputation
um multiple imputation does that
multiple times so simply instead of
having one
version or one imputed version of the
data now we have multiple inputed
version
and this is actually to account for the
uncertainty of our guess or estimate for
the missing values and if you wanted
these
uh let's say the the new set of data
sets in your
task the machine learning or data
science tasks you have in your hand
you may either apply your analysis on
all of these data
sets individually and then do some
combination and pooling in the end
like what you're doing on some learning
for example or if you want to train in
neural network for example you can
simply let the neural network be trained
on all of them together
in that case you are transferring the
uncertainty from the data to the
parameters of your neural network
the other way to let's say categorize
the
methodologies for imputation can be
viewed as the model that you use it can
be either discriminative models or
generative models in the discriminative
models
you already assume that there is a
correlation between
missing variables with missing values
and the observed variables
and that's why you want to actually
find this correlation by estimating a
function but for
and for generative models you may what
you want to do is to estimate the
distribution of the data the variable
which has missing values if it's
completely at random then
only the normal uh
distribution but if it's uh missing at
random and there is a dependency between
observer and variables may estimate the
conditional distribution as for the
single imputation
um well uh maybe this is the most common
type of imputation we do
uh as i explained we want to have one
version or one
in complete version of the data and
there are a number of approaches you can
just go to the literature and you'll
find tens of them
uh well some some examples are mean or
median imputation simply looking at the
observed uh
very values and then take the mean fill
in the missing values
you can use k nearest neighbor or k n
approach in that case you consider a
neighborhood for the sample with missing
values and
do the imputation according to samples
in that neighborhood
or you may benefit from some predictable
discriminative models
like linear regression neural network
random for us whatever it is you simply
look at the
data the complete part of the data and
you want to train a model
uh which maps the uh observed variables
uh
to to the variable with missing values
and then
use that model to do the imputation
whenever data is missing right
and there are a number of other methods
to like matrix completion you may
benefit from pca or expectation
maximization but
uh no matter what method you use as long
as you're doing single imputation you
don't account for uncertainty
and like i said uh one popular approach
to cope with that problem
is to benefit from multiple imputation
and there are a number of ways to do so
for example buddha strapping by stop
selecting uh the data
from with replacement of course and do
the imputation to the soft selection
again to the imputation
and uh just just continue like that to
have number of invitation
version or generative models as i said
you estimated distribution so you can
draw samples from this
distribution and you can draw multiple
samples to fill in the missing values
you may benefit from multiple
imputation techniques or discriminative
models like uh one version is coming
from neural network computation the
other from random forest
and even in any of some of these methods
you can already play around with the
random seed
parameters to have multiple version of
imputation even using one discriminative
models
and there are other popular techniques
too like mice which
stands for multivariate imputation with
chained equation this is
actually a very uh popular one which is
used in industrial application and
the way it works is that it does the
imputation in a round-robin fashion so
it starts from the incomplete data it
does some
uh initial imputation like mean
imputation so in the cycle one
just focus on one variable it tries to
estimate the missing values according to
the observed one then go to the next
cycle
fix what is being uh imputed in the
first cycle then in the second cycle it
goes to the next one
does the imputation for that and uh
continues until all the variables are
imputed and you can do the same thing
from a scratch multiple times to have
multiple version of the
imputation or in the denoising other
encoder what you do
is to benefit from an over over complete
uh auto encoder it's a black box model
is a neural network which takes the
um well the input is the missing value
or the
sorry incomplete data where the missing
entries are filled in with
uh some random noise and it learns to
map that to the complete data right and
in the test you can benefit from that
for imputation
so there are two uh well actually there
are many but there are two uh
let's say uh challenging yet very
practical and helpful topics i'm
personally very excited about and i want
to talk about them
in this slide uh one of them is
exploiting target or output for
imputation
and when i'm saying target or output i
mean when you have a task like
um classification or regression then you
want to
estimate or predict something that's
called target and
you can already say that it's not as
straightforward and can be very
difficult because target is the most
mysterious type of missingness that we
want to estimate uh
well at the end of the day
and um but there are some scenarios and
situation that we actually
this target can be helpful but maybe
indirectly in the training phase at
least
to uh have a good imputation and
i don't want to go to all the well
let's say details of that but just to
give you an idea that
how it's possible i would like to show
you actually
talk about one example uh which is
extreme gradient boosting
method uh well this is uh the one
actually if you use the package it does
the imputation according to that
and uh well it's a decision tree based
method and so what it does is that
um uh when the model is being trained
you are actually training a threshold
for each node and let's assume that we
have only two split at each node
so when the variable comes uh parent
node
then we want to decide whether to go to
the right or to the left but if the
variable has missing values what the
algorithm does is that it goes on both
sides
and it calculates the loss function
values for both
sides so in the end and the last
function is
uh considering the target right so uh in
the end of the training you
you have two loss function values for
both sides and the one which is a
smaller
is going to be considered uh for the
default so the the direction which
actually resulted in the lower loss
function value will be considered as a
default and in the test phase
that direction will be used whenever
that variable has missing values
another issue is availability of the
complete data
for majority of the algorithms or
techniques i've talked about so far we
need to have access to the complete data
like for example
the noising auto encoder but in practice
sometimes it's even impossible to have
the complete version of the data
and it's important to somehow benefit
from even the incomplete version of the
data during
training and um there are again it's
very active area is an interesting
uh and active area in the community and
uh just again to give you an idea that
how it might be possible
possible i'm going to refer to one
example which is based on generative
adversarial neural networks
for example gain or there is another
approach is called miscan
you may refer to them there are fairly
new uh methods
so what it does is that next to the data
it considers
another data structure which is called
mask vector or mask
matrix which represents um
which entry is missing and which one is
there
and um then the generator in the
gen framework uh which is the imputer
actually for us does the imputation
but since we don't have access to the
real version or the complete version of
the data or the discriminator or critic
cannot
look at that one but it looks at the
mask vector and it tries to estimate the
mask vector
and how good the discriminator can make
the mask vector means that
how good or bad the generator worked so
this is just a brief
overview of the algorithm of course the
way it's being implemented as being
proposed is a bit more complicated and
but
hopefully you have the idea that how you
can turn the problem so that you can
benefit from the incomplete data too
all right and in the end i want to show
you some results illustrative results
from emini state set uh which is a date
set of
uh images of digi digits and
uh i have used a cycle learning pewter
and fancy computer to open source
toolboxes actually with number of
interesting
imputation techniques and these are the
results from the notebooks i
said uh will make it available for you
so you can simply reproduce these
results yourself
so what i did was that i artificially
induced
or well induced 20 missingness in the
data as you can see in the bottom
and then i tried number of imputation
techniques so for the single imputation
i tried like median mean and k n
amputation
and you can already see that for example
a median or canon works better than the
mean imputation
and you can do that with both socket
learn and fancy impute
the other one is mice and the noising
auto encoder these are multiple
imputation techniques
uh for the mice i use fancy impute and
it adds some artifacts
according to the estimator you use and
the noising auto encoder is
implemented with cross you'll see in the
notebook and you can already see how
well denoising autoencoder works uh with
imputation
and finally the generative adversarial
method which is the gain
imputation and in this case the
difference is that the training data
didn't have the complete version of the
data so all the data including
i mean test and train both had missing
values and it's somehow impressive that
even with that
it can make generate the samples like
this
so again for the gain imputation also
i'll make a separate notebook available
uh so for those of you who are maybe
more advanced in imputation then you can
refer to that
all right as a take away or
let's say the conclusion maybe the most
important thing that i would like to
emphasize
is that when you're facing missingness
in your data
before choosing the algorithm or the
methodology to work around it
you need to have a good understanding of
your data what uh
is the missing missingness type uh what
are the other factors like the size of
the data if there is a correlation
between observed variables and
missing variables or not and then go to
uh write go to find the right method
there are a number of them available out
there
also i would like to um suggest you to
look at multiple invitation more
because well of course it's going to
come with
extra work and maybe extra computation
but sometimes
um it's very it's the only way to to
actually
consider or account for the uncertainty
of your invitation
and be careful about the open source
toolboxes you use some of them
because of the uh i mean missingness is
a common issue so some of them
do some default action so be careful
about them do not leave it up to your
packages to decide for you what to do uh
but do it yourself and if you are
interested in more uh let's say
advanced methodology check the
literature where we're very uh
high-ranking conferences like icml new
rips
they i mean every year you can see a
number of interesting paper and missing
data imputation
all right that that that's it um yeah so
we have enough time maybe for some
questions yeah for some questions um
uh i do have a question uh myself and i
hope you're familiar maybe with this
um i think uh andrew gellman he also
wrote in his book about data imputation
and he's doing something very
specifically there
so what he's doing is saying okay you
shouldn't impute with an expected value
because the data won't look like the
original data anymore because the noise
is out
so um he then adds the venom noise into
the data
so uh what are your thoughts on that uh
yeah
that's a good point actually one of um i
mean
this is maybe uh well that reminds me of
a comment i received
from a colleague of mine said that we
are not magicians we are not supposed to
create what doesn't exist
but uh the reason that we need to do
imputation
as i mentioned in the arab one of the
earlier slides is that sometimes we have
to
do that because for example if you want
to
benefit from methodologies ai
methodologies or modeling techniques
which are coming on daily basis these
days
many of them rely on the assumption that
data is complete
so if the data is incomplete we have to
somehow find a complete version of that
otherwise we cannot do anything we
cannot
benefit from the algorithm which is out
there and
we need to do that so we just have to be
careful
not to add too much noise or bias on the
data and that's actually a good
question because my um my hope was that
to
convey this message that be very careful
about the
missing data imputation you use uh by
collecting
enough information about the structure
of the data the type of the missingness
and by that you may
reduce the type amount of the noise or
bias you will add to the data
by imputing yeah so basically you're
saying if you have to do imputation you
always introduce some kind of bias in
to your data so you should be very
careful on how you do it
exactly yeah yeah so um i don't know
whether you have an experience with
whether you should or should not be
adding additional noise in your
imputation
but my line of thought here is that it
might actually be a bad thing to do
because it could be if you do some kind
of inference for example
that you introduce some new biases
you have a thing called measurement
error or attenuation bias and actually
because you're adding noise to the model
uh
your effects that you get out of the
model
yeah they tend to be closer to zero yeah
yeah so
it maybe depends a little bit on whether
you're doing inference or doing some
kind of machine learning
yes yes also it depends on what you're
going to do in a stat
i mean if you don't impute what's the
next option ignore them
or use a methodology which is capable of
i don't know benefiting from missing
data like extreme gradient boosting for
example
if it's ignoring then again um
it's important to know if let's say you
have
two examples with missing data out of
thousands then
it's safe to not impute and ignore them
and do your inference or modeling
whatever you want to do with the rest of
the data
but if it's 50 of the data and you just
want to remove them you're
removing or ignoring half of the
information in your data
and maybe then again it's up to you as a
scientist to engineer to decide which
one is more dangerous right
imputing and adding some noise or
removing
and uh being totally blind about the
information in that part
yeah so there is as i said there is no
one-size-fits-all solution
so it's at the at the end of the day
it's up to you to decide
uh what is uh not let's say the
the best but what is the uh these were
the least
worst technique to to connect with
missing that's really interesting
especially like filtering data out it
takes a really strong perspective
because
you can say oh i have enough data
anyways but you can induce the bias by
kicking the other things out
yeah yeah yeah very good point yeah
okay yeah perfect um so
i'm taking a look at the time we don't
have the clock
anymore so we leave finish a little bit
earlier i suppose all right
with a thought uh problem thank you very
much for your talk thank you we're
already having a
conversation about it that yeah it was
really great and
clear very nice yeah